[Musique]
guillon a évité sa maman marie au
restaurant quand il vient chercher sa
mère à la résidence pour retraités
il s'agit d'une opération bien
chorégraphiés et stationnent loto et
s'élance vers l'entrée il monte au 20ème
étage
sa mère est prête sur le pas de la porte
cinq minutes plus tard top chrono
guillon mais sa mère sont dans l'auto
mais surprise sur le pare brise une
contravention de 53 dollars
guillon ne comprends pas il s'est garé
cinq minutes et 6 5 minutes de trop en
vertu du code de la sécurité routière un
débarcadère n'autorise pas le
stationnement son rôle indique ça doit
servir qu'à l'embarquement ou au
débarquement des passagers
même si guillaume avait attendu sa mère
dans le véhicule
il ne peut pas s'arrêter là par contre
cela devient possible lorsque le panneau
indique une durée d'utilisation maximale
le samu l'histoire même si vous battez
des records de rapidité
le débarcadère ce n'est pas pour se
garer